mr. we're in the middle of a major
national and global crisis and yet at
this moment labour seems to have a lot
of energy and attention being consumed
into the discussions around the contents
of this internal report into the
failings to handle anti-semitism
complaints do you agree with Kirsten
Marin when he says he's disappointed
that it's in the public domain yes I am
I shouldn't it should never have been
leaked look our focus is about
coronavirus and how we save lives but
that's what our focus is now but the
report is out there now so we've got to
deal with it and it should never have
been read a certain shouldn't be meeting
a redacted for unredacted former names
over so that's that's wrong . but now
it's out though we've got to deal with
the content of it it's it's not our
priority issue but we've got to deal
with it because i think a lot of our
party members and supporters well
they'll like me they're pretty shocked
and actually pretty angry and the
neutral in this context in 2017 we now
discover if this is true if this is
accurate this report that a group of
staff senior staff but try to undermine
the election of a Labour government and
if it is true of course it's that's
appalling and we came within the last
estimate was we came with about to a
half thousand votes of having a Labour
government that's how close we were and
what does that mean it means just take
the current coronavirus outbreak I think
we would have been much better prepared
because we would have been three years
into a Labour gun with a fully funded
NHS we would those nurses and the health
workers that we go out and clap for they
would have had their pay rise a decent
pay rise that the Conservatives blocked
and also we would have established the
national care service that we'd planned
in that election so it has a real impact
on the real world and very vulnerable
people now understandably the people who
really need a Labour government didn't
get it and that's why people are angry
so of course coronaviruses are it's a
key issue we're facing we're all
fighting in our constituencies and
nationally
now this is out there we've got to deal
with it we've got to reassure our
members it is being dealt with this
culture this culture that was in the
party at the time is eradicated the key
Astana has launched an independent
investigation with his deputy Angela
Rainer he said it will look at the
contents of the report as well as the
commissioning and he's urged colleagues
to refrain from commenting while that
report continues so why do you feel you
need to speak out the person say why
he's doing this I'm not staying we've
lost members we're losing members I was
told yesterday of the weekend I don't
know it says accurate not but we 3,000
members of gong that's left us so we've
got to get the message out there kids
doing the right thing he has my 100%
support investigation and he said as
well yesterday that investigation will
be independent and it would be fast he's
doing the right thing nobody expect to
go a bit further though and look if the
people who've been named in this report
we don't know whether it's true not
these are allegations but in normal
circumstances they should be treated
like every other party member if there
are serious charges allegations made
against an individual party member the
normal process is that you get suspended
and that's what should happen to those
named in this report because if it is
true these are serious allegations but
is this a normal process I guess that's
the question that should be put back to
you in the sense that there is this
investigation going on
these were whatsapp messages and it's
very unclear how they made it into hands
off the governance and legal units under
the jeremy corbyn's leadership when you
were second in command if you like and
is there not is it not right that
actually this investigation looks at how
those messages were and you convinced
other people let's go through it the
reality of it
Kyra said the investigation will look
into who Commission how that was
commissioned my understanding is the
general secretary commissioned that the
thought I was not involved that's not
for me to comment on of that but the
general sense commissioned that report
was part of the submission to the HRC
investigation that's the first thing
because they will look into that he said
also like me this has been leaked in on
route
to perform and that's wrong and that
will be looked at as well the key issue
though is the content of this report if
it is true it cannot be denied that this
is incredibly serious we're talking
about a culture within the labour party
to undermine the election of a Labour
government when it was so desperately
needed so action these I think most of
our members will need to be reassured
that in addition to the investigation
action is taken now as well on the base
least serious charges people should be
treated fairly overall and of course the
investigation will look into these
matters but just as other members when
serious charges have been made against
them they've been suspended I think this
should happen them if let me just say
this though if the investigation finds
that this report is accurate these
members shuffle be expelled and should
never be around back into the labour
party ever again because this is serious
matters now you've asked me the question
of how this information has gone into
the report my understanding is that this
is all internal labour thought
e-communications
the EHR C asks that all those internal
communications should be made of
Albertan that's exactly what happened
here my understanding about whatsapp
group information that was contained in
some of this is actually was placed onto
the internal email or email system or
communication system but labour party so
that's if it's available it should be
that we should there should be no there
should be no hiding of this has got to
be full and open and transparent if this
was going on and if it is true this is
absolutely appalling you've said that
this report was commissioned do you
believe by Jenny Formby
in order to be a submission to the
equalities and Human Rights Commission
do you believe that this report will
help or hinder the party's case when it
comes to defending the accusation that
the Labour Party is institutionally
anti-semitic in terms of racism I think
I think the truth has got to come out I
just give one example from what I've
seen in the report
I was asking consistently about why
cases were being dealt with so slowly
in one instance as
I asked a question someone had been
suspended and then a suspension had been
lifted I said why is that happened all
the way along the expressions I was
using is that the Labour Party this is
my criticism
we're not quick enough not fast enough
into your cases and we're not ruthless
enough that's the language I used in
this report it appears that one of the
senior staffers when the senior members
of staff when I made those and I made
those comments I was told to grow up
they undermined I think if this report
is true what this culture within senior
echelons of the staff of the lay pod if
it is true undermined our ability to
effectively deal with anti-semitism and
what this report does do as well it
nails all these ridiculous conspiracy
theories it says there was anti-semitism
it was significant exactly a sunburst
said and it needed to be dealt with and
what this report if it is true reveals
is the factionalism that was being
displayed by certain senior staff
members if it is true was undermining
our ability to do that that's the most
one of the most appalling things of this
but if you're saying that this report is
I mean what I take from what you just
said is that you think that this report
is likely to increase the chances that
the eh RC will find labour to have been
institutionally racist and if that is
the case surely there will be those that
say that by making that the case by
exposing the degree of factionalism
which many in your party say that he
knew all about anyway
this is a scorched-earth mentality isn't
it the initial England and and putting
this report into the public domain no
not at all whatever allows the HC et HRC
to find the truth is the key issue so
everything in this report if it is true
should be exposed to the HRC they've got
to have access to all the information
we've got to rid ourselves of this
culture that prevented a Labour
government when we desperately needed
one but also by the looks of it also
undermined the party's ability to do
anti-semitism effectively so the ERC
should have everything like warts and
all what's a little and if that means
the e actually comes to a finding saying
that the Labour Party is institutionally
anti-semitic well
so be it but we've got to rid ourselves
I do not want care I here's a friend of
mine I support him I back him on what
he's doing on this on this in this
report I backed the investigation he set
up the independent he said it would be
fast I'm back that we don't want him to
face ever this sort of culture of
factionalism undermining the leader of
the Labour Party is Jeremy Corbyn face
obviously if this report is true
the thing is though when the Jewish
community are listening to the internal
debate that is going on here and you say
things like if the eh RC finds labour
institutionally anti-semitic so be it
that played into exactly what we've been
hearing from some let me read you this
tweet from Peter Mason who's the
National Secretary of the Jewish labor
movement he says the overwhelming
feeling in all of this is disgust
once again Jews are one other ones made
to feel like absolute pawns in a game of
someone else's design isn't that you say
so obvious no not at all quite the
reverse I've worked with feet amazing I
make it absolutely clear if the ar e HRC
comes along and asks for information
from the Labour Party about its role in
tackling anti centers they should have
everything everything no holds barred if
they then come to the conclusion but
actually the Labour Party failed to
address anti-semitism and they make
their recommendations we implement them
we've got to get this cleared up once
and for all
I understand where Peters coming from
this isn't about using people or pawns
or individuals or groups or whatever
this is the search for the truth because
I've had enough I had years of asking
what was happening on anti-semitism we
were being told according to this report
inaccurate information consistently if
it's true that's appalling we should
never allow this ever to happen again
we've got to end this culture now many
of the staff were named in this report
and we left the Labour Party of the
party employment if that is the case
fair enough we'll see what happens as a
result of this investigation
but if there are members of staff still
with us who are named in the support
and this accurate this report is proved
to be accurate I expect the Labour Party
to take the appropriate action if there
are people who have left the Labour
Party's employee and this investigation
finds that this report is true I will
expect the lame party to take legal
advice on what the party should be doing
in that instance as well it all depends
on whether or not this report is true or
not but I tell you it is worrying me and
is worrying labour party members to the
extent that some that people have left
the party and I say to them stay with us
because we need you to help us sort this
out
just finally clearly divisions in
political parties are part of politics
the Conservatives to be wracked with
between Euroskeptic senior Isles but
this is something different isn't it
isn't what this report isn't what this
reports show is that the Labour Party
cannot accommodate the ideological or
political spectrum that it has tried to
that it is not a big enough tent and
that the visceral personal hatred of one
another means that it is not like
something that can work we've had a
hundred years of a Labour Party in which
we've been a broad Church a broad church
we've accommodated range of views left
center right and we've we've hung
together abroad all of it that's the way
we get better politics disagreement you
know don't don't mistake disagreement
and different views from from descent in
its democracy that's democracy and we've
held together for over a century what if
this report is true what's happened here
is a very small group a very small group
developed a culture in the highest
echelon of the Labour Party to undermine
the ability of a Labour government to be
elected we were founded as a party to
represent people and get a Labour gum
elected to change the world now if this
report is true this group prevented a
Labour government elected when we
desperately needed one that's why so
many people are shocked like me and
angered like me and that's why Kier will
sort it with this investigation
but there needs to be I think some
elements of prompter action before then
so we can reassure our members that we
are taking it seriously smooth on a fake
very much